okay so rebecca has a lot of things to
live up to
not only is it based on a classic novel
the film adaptation by alfred hitchcock
also won best picture in 1940
it's got some big high heels to fill and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the movie story
it's crazy ending and the differences to
the source material
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check out
the film yet then i highly recommend
that you check out now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
breakdown
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul
aka the guy that's always at your
rebecca and call
now let's get into the video okay so
rebecca primarily follows lily james's
character
who is only ever known as mrs dewinter
whilst leaving a character's name out of
a script it's pretty lazy writing
it's actually been done for a specific
reason and that is to paint out the
purpose of the character
mrs dewinter is pretty much viewed as a
stand-in for mr dewinter's deceased wife
rebecca
and we see she tries her best to come to
terms with this
whilst also discovering what really
happened to her
mr maxim dewinter played by army hammer
is apparently grieving due to his wife's
drowning the year before
and there's a large hole in his life
that not only looms over him
but also his estate known simply as
mandalay
throughout the introduction of the movie
we watch as mr and mrs are introduced to
one another
and they fall in love due to the class
system in england
mrs is pretty much viewed as an object a
staff member
rather than a person and thus when maxim
plucks her out of this
she's naturally swept off her feet the
first act of the film
could be mistaken for a classic romance
story and we watch as the pair
get to know each other fall in love and
get married
faster than you can say viva las vegas
however the dynamic quickly changes when
mrs arrives at mandalay
and finds that rebecca's ghost very much
still resides in the house
although there's nothing supernatural
about the events the film does a good
job of making you feel like there's a
presence in the manner
though this never truly manifests even
with its faults i did find that the
movie achieved its goal of making us
feel like something else was a foot here
a 40 40 i can't believe i've said that
i've been
been watching far too many of these
period pieces recently
anyway at mandalay resides mrs danvers
played by kristen scott thomas dan
visits the head of the household
and we learned that she cared for
rebecca throughout pretty much her
entire life
because of this she remains incredibly
loyal to her
and even in death very much feels like
she must still serve her
this devotion makes her gain an instant
dislike to mrs
who she views as being a shallow
replacement mrs danvers pretty much
becomes a vessel
for rebecca's vengeful spirit and by
proxy she torments misses
similar to how rebecca tormented maxim
yes or no i'm calling her mrs
i'm sorry now danvers does whatever she
can to destroy mr and mrs relationship
but missus fights on through it all now
this mirrors an earlier encounter with
mrs boss
in which she mocks their relationship
and says that they aren't a good fit
because of their social status
no one puts my hat on me no one i tell
you now throughout the film
we learned that rebecca didn't die in an
accident and that maxim actually killed
her
rebecca was diagnosed with cancer of the
uterus and with only months left to live
she decided to enact a plan that would
rob maxim of feeling guilt-free over her
passing
rebecca was known for her beauty and she
didn't want to have a frail dying woman
being the last thing that people
remembered her as thus
she pretended to be pregnant and
provoked maxim into killing her
in the hopes that he would go to prison
because the death looked like an
accident
maxim was exonerated of her death but
rebecca still very much haunts him
now though most stories that follow this
aesthetic would very much end with mrs
getting chased through the mansion by mr
with an
axe rebecca is a lot more understanding
of maxim's predicament
the movie pretty much paints him out as
someone who was mentally abused by his
wife
and the constant torment that he faced
very much made his life a living hell
rebecca cheated on him often and
threatened him with humiliation at
several points
because of the said class system and the
legacy of mandalay
maxim very much felt that if their
relationship troubles were made public
that this would bring shame to his
family name and thus he kept it a secret
maxim was very much forced to kill her
in order to stop her not only taking
away his pride
but also his home name and a legacy that
his family had built
maxim believed that rebecca was pregnant
with an illegitimate heir between
rebecca and her cousin jack
that because he wouldn't go public about
would mean that the home would be passed
over to someone else that wasn't a true
de winter
now whilst this wasn't true it was
enough to make maxim kill her
which was her ultimate end game maxim
faked the drowning
and sunk the boat she was in pushing it
out to sea
in order to cover up the crime a woman's
body later washed up on the shore
and maxim identified her as rebecca even
though this was just a jane doe
however the boat is soon discovered
along with rebecca's corpse
and due to the punctures in the hull it
makes it clear that a death was no
accident
after a letter is discovered submitting
jack all things point towards maxim and
he's arrested
maxim becomes the prime suspect in her
death and the movie takes a sharp turn
for the finale
now luckily for maxim rebecca's tumor is
discovered
and due to her being clearly short on
time suicide is instead listed as the
cause of her death
which exonerates maxim however danvers
doesn't want to allow maxim to win in
the end
and because of her devotion to rebecca
she burns down mandalay in order to
destroy his legacy before she throws
herself into the sea
honestly it feels like a completely
weird
ending and one that's a bit messy until
you look at the true meaning behind it
now as mentioned earlier danvers is
pretty much the personification of
rebecca
and metaphorically this is very much her
destroying the mana in the end
rebecca wanted nothing more than to tear
maxim's life apart
and thus danvers carrying this out
symbolically shows that she achieved her
goal in the end
however it shouldn't really be classed
as a victory and danvers tossing herself
into the sea
can also be seen as the last shred of
rebecca's presence
dying along with her this is why we cut
almost immediately to both mr and mrs
finally sharing
some real happiness together in a new
home not only are they free of the mana
which rebecca was so tightly bound to
but they're also free of rebecca herself
danvers tells mrs dewinter that she will
never know happiness
and personally i think it's the parting
words of the bitter rebecca
who wanted nothing more than to ruin
maxim's life but failed in doing so
missus definitely says that she will
find happiness as very much seen
as a victory for the character
throughout danvers constantly tried to
compare misses to rebecca
and often commented on how she wasn't as
beautiful as she was
she even made her dress up as her in
order to embarrass her and tried to show
that she simply couldn't live up to her
however that is where mrs succeeded and
because
she was such an opposite to rebecca she
was actually a better fit for maxim
maxim wanted nothing more than a woman
who wasn't cruel to him
genuinely loved him and wouldn't try to
emotionally abuse
him this is why mrs is so perfect for
him
and why she shouldn't have been so upset
about being compared to rebecca
in the end mr and mrs have escaped from
everything that rebecca held over them
and they can now move in a new direction
without her ghost hanging over them
now this is a sort of happy ending if my
interpretation
is correct and it's actually why the
original film
differed so much due to laws at the time
known as the haze code
filmmakers were unable to portray a
woman's death in a positive light
it was also classed as highly immoral to
show people getting away with murder
and thus maxim could not be seen getting
away and punished
in the original rebecca's death is
accidental
and she dies from hitting her head
during a fall there are other
differences such as favel being called
for by maxim
in order to look over the letter which
does add some weight towards his
innocence
the finale also ends with mrs danvers
going to rebecca's room
as the mansion burns around her and she
dies in the foundations
symbolically taking rebecca with her too
now both endings are very much seen as
an exorcism
and they should be classed as the send
off to rebecca rather than the way that
they're initially portrayed with her and
danvers winning
either way that wraps up the movie and
before we get into the review i just
want to let you know we're giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october so make sure you
get involved
now what were my thoughts on the film
well lois getting
slammed pretty badly by the critics i
don't think it's a complete train crash
yet don't don't throw yourself off a
cliff director please i'm begging you
much like mrs and rebecca herself the
movie is being compared to the original
and that's something that's very
difficult to live up to
now if you go in with either the novel
or the 1940 film looming over your head
much like danvers you're not going to
see this as matching up
the chemistry isn't really there between
the two winters
and at times it plods along not really
advancing the plot
however when viewed on its own i don't
think it's that bad
and for a midweek movie on netflix it's
a it's absolutely fine
it's it's fine isn't it i think a lot of
people
will probably enjoy this to a certain
extent and no it's not a new classic
if this is your first time experiencing
the story you'll probably find some
stuff to like here
rebecca was fine and it gets a 6 out of
10
and and we'll have away with all that
nonsense about it being
a complete piece of crap anyway now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
make sure you check out our breakdown on
the third day which is going to be
linked at the end
we go over the weird season and it's
ending so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat with us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
foreign